Мені здається що ми закріпили розвиток
танкової коаліції тому що проговорено
сьогодні підписано меморандум щодо разом
з польськими партнерами і німецькими
партнерами паном маріусом блажчиком
Борисом історію сам про те що ми будемо
мати проект по розвитку запчастин і
обслуговування танків леопард леопард
леопард 1 ми будемо їх мати достатньо і
Крім того ми говорили про боєприпаси для
танту це дуже важливий орган
додатковий аспект крім того Сьогодні
знову устами Лойда остіна та марка Міллі
прозвучала на підтримку нашої пози
що система протиповітряної оборони Це
номер один задача для допомоги Україні
від всіх систем і це було почуто
партнерами і були навіть озвучені деякі
пакети які ми отримуємо в найближчим
часом друге - це
готовність наших партнерів
тривалий час працювати на перемогу
України а це означає
підготовчі курси тренінго
вий мій запчастини
обслуговування і оновлення озброєння і
саме головне замовлення у
військово-промислового комплексу
країн-партнерів амуніції набої снарядів
патронів і так далі І так далі це
важливі речі які дають нам з вами
абсолютно впевненість нашої Перемоги
Чому тому що ця війна яка по суті
найбіль- найстрашніша війна за 80 років
на планеті Земля
повна машина це війна ресурс і за нашою
спиною стоять ресурси цивілізованого
світу і цивілізований світ
чергове підтвердив що вони готові бути з
нами Разом до нашої з вами Перемоги
війська з
е-е reparation restoration and
Mafia Games
Слава Україні
одне запитання якщо можна
ми зробили так але дякую Дякую за ваш
час просто Да Це прямий ефір Отже пана
рисунко Скажіть будь ласка наскільки
західні партнери розуміють що в мозаїці
ПВО протиповітряної е-е оборони саме
західні винищувачі мають бути власне
одним з головних елементів але при цьому
вони кажуть зараз акцент тільки на ті
засоби пфу які землі мають дивіться
партнери це знають але називати це одним
з головних це напевно Ну я би так не
говорив це один із важливих елементів
Але якщо ти не маєш системи ППО на Землі
серйозною яка спроможні перехоплювати
балістичні ракети крилаті ракети то тобі
недостатньо буде тільки літаки літаки
поповнюють або заміщують ті прогалини
які виникають якщо не справляється
система наземного захисту неба Тому це
інтегровані системи разом і ми це
доносимо партнер і вони це розуміють але
партнери я це повторюю повторюю дуже
осудливо приймають своє рішення що вже
реально нам дати вже і зараз і вже і
зараз реальніше поставити системи які
базуються на землі ракети до них Це дуже
важливо вони є у всіх партнерів і це
може посилити і спроможність нашої
протиповітряної оборони літаки вимагають
більш довгого навчання більш складної
системи обслуговування відновлення і
відповідно потім застосування але це не
означає що ми їх не отримаємо
український пілоти завжди вчаться але
поки що сказати що вони вчаться на тих
системах їм ми отримуємо я не можу тому
що ще не вирішено принципово питань які
саме літаки будуть тому але ми готові ми
готові все дякую Всіх благ правда
Отже шановні глядачі до очей волю
українського ви бачили наскільки
популярний український міністр оборони з
ним фотографуються американські солдати
Отже Ми продовжуємо пряме включення
звідси з Rammstein Вибачте що тут трохи
камера стоїть криво бо зараз вже з цієї
військової бази намагаються вигнати
пресу Це військовий об'єкт зрозуміло
Отже підіб'ємо певні підсумки того про
що було домовлено на цьому вже 11
Rammstein нагадаю що саме ППО
протиповітряної протиракетно-оборони -
це дві головні теми цьогорічного
Rammstein 11 з них саме надання ракет до
тих комплексів які вже працюють в
Україні а їх чимало це і французький
кроталь і німецькі гепард і ірісте до
речі цей зрк не досі не стоїть на
бойовому чергуванні у Німеччині
бундесфері але вже є в Україні і добре
себе зарекомендував вже дві два
комплекси поставлено в Україні також
нещодавно було офіційно оголошено про те
що американські патріоти вже на бойовому
чергуванні і так далі Зараз Україна
потребує безумовно ракет великої
дальності щоб можна було бити на 300 км
відповідно вражати пункти командування
не Склади і живу силу російської армії
поки що рішення про це немає але ти не
менш українська делегація тут
наполегливо продавлюють цю тему так само
як і надання
українським збройним силам західних
винищувачів зокрема f-16 ви щойно чули
не про що сказав міністр оборони Олексій
рейсніков відповідно що не цей процес
ідеї українській плоти можливо теж
вчаться він офіційно це не підтвердив
так жортома сказав що так а українські
пілоти завжди вчаться
крім того ж таки варто зауважити що саме
тут на Rammstein сконцентрувалися на
тому що було зроблено за рік адже рівно
рік тому було оголошено про Цей формат
формат контактної групи для оборони
України Так от були підбиток підсумки
скільки було надано всього і скільки має
бути надано зокрема Сполучені Штати
надали військовою допомоги на понад 35
мільярдів доларів тисячі солдатів
пройшло тренування у Канаді у Сполучених
Штатах понад 16 тисяч України Європи
також тисячі солдатів пройшли тренування
у Великій Британії і зараз всі ці сили
не повертаються в Україну готуються до
контурнаступу Звісно що тема Контр
наступу Також тут вітаю в кулуарах це не
було порядком денного обговорення але це
безумовно обговорювалося і на
прес-конференції декілька разів
запитували міністра оборони Сполучених
Штатів
Ллойда осьтіна зокрема очі вірить він в
успіх цього контрнаступу на що він
звісно конкретних дат і термінів чи які
сили будуть задіяні Він не сказав чи які
напрямок напрямок удару і так далі але
він сказав що від успіху цього
контрнаступу буде залежати власне він
важливий не лише для України а для всіх
цивілізованих країн щоб довести що якщо
є агресивна країна вона не має не
повинна нападати на своїх сусідів також
безумовно було обговорено про те що
надавати боєприпаси амуніція амуніція -
це ще раз амуніція зокрема для
артилерійських систем різних
артилерійських систем і самохідних
артларійських установок і гаубиць
зокрема це не йдеться мова про снаряди
калібру 155 мм а також інших було знову
ж таки домовлено і європейські Союз ним
теж координується прискорення
виробництва саме
використовувати потужності європейських
країн для виробництва цих снарядів і
потім постачання їх в Україну крім того
безумовно обговорювалися про подальше
тренування українських військових про
надання стрілецької зброї зокрема Канада
пообіцяла снайперських гвинтівки та
амуніціо бимов безумовно мова йде про
безпілотники про дрони антидрони і так
далі І так далі е-е знову ж таки варто
зазначити і от тут от був якраз от
буквально декілька хвилин тому теж і е
генсек НАТО Який е-е ще зранку е казав
що зараз битва в Україні переходить у
такий собі бій
Логістик тобто хто краще налагодить цю
логістику постачання зброї
ремонту так знову ж таки запчастин і так
далі той і виграє Тому зараз основний
акцент на те щоби створювати саме цю
логістику тому що всі якось завжди
акцентують от яке на виозброєння було
надано Що нового е-е і так далі тут
важливо зараз вважають західні партнери
України сконцентруватися саме на тому
щоб постачати запчастини і за бойові і
боєприпаси і так далі до тих систем які
вже добре присутні в Україні Зеніт у
ракетні комплекси ті самі хаймерси
реакти системи реактивно реактивні
системи залпового вогню і так далі Ну і
безумовно бо і припаси для них
тож цей Рамштайн 11 українська делегація
вважає успішним так не повертається
українська делегація на крилах f16 але
це не означає що
Авіаційна коаліція не створена вона
створена вона діє і одним з головних
елементів має бути знову ж таки надання
західних винищувачів зокрема f-16 тобто
в цьому пазлі нинішньому зараз ППО
протиповітряної оборони проти ракетної
оборони не вистачає зараз фактично
тільки винищувачів західного зразка Який
З часом все ж таки будуть надані Отже
Дякую вам шановні глядачі за те що були
з нами ви щойно могли побачити і в
прямому ефірі підхід до преси міністра
оборони України Олексія резнікова а
також короткі підсумки про те чим
закінчився 11 Рамштайн Мене звати Максим
Драбов До побачення і залишайтеся з
доччиною